[Music]
i find out that you are uh serious about
astronomy you really like it well
um yeah i mean i need something to
balance out the ufc thing right sure
yeah you've got that and the flip side
is astronomy i'm so complicated yeah
very layered i
i
i'm an [ __ ]
well you could always beat someone with
a telescope
a couple of years ago i did this trip
that i really put a lot of time and
effort into which you know like i don't
normally do this but i did this trip to
turkey because there was a full eclipse
happening in turkey and i did a ton of
research to like figure out
where to go where was the best place to
view it where there was like going to be
nobody else and like i'm serious because
to fly to turkey just to see an eclipse
is pretty amazing i mean i just i've
always wanted to go to turkey as well so
i turned i turned the whole thing into
like a three and a half week trip where
part of it was a road trip and i was
like sleeping in people's apartments and
like really just amazing trip right so
the day
of the eclipse i you've it's like a
four-hour hike
to get to this one spot that every
website and every book told me this is
where you have to watch as a clip
eclipse and i'm
i'm up there and and it's they're right
it's amazing there's only like three
other people it's really quiet and
and this amazing thing happens right
before an eclipse it goes really quiet
and then the birds like go nuts
and it's the the light kind of drops and
then
this
woman started playing a guitar and
singing
that for non-blonde song hey
what's going on
as the eclipse was happening i thought
and she didn't stop she sang it for the
entire eclipse she just kept singing
that
linda perry song over and over and over
and over and over again so you've
traveled all the way to turkey for
solitude and you're listening to a woman
sing this song
you don't even know like i
i i would like a part of me died that
day
died that day and i let look linda perry
you're awesome but yeah that person just
ruined ruined your eclipse yeah
did you not want to just go like
you know like you know i think i did
that horrible thing where you just look
at someone
you know you do the look like yeah and
and she was just like just so peace and
love and you know right she couldn't
interpret that as i try to give people
the look and they always think i'm
coming on to them you know
no one ever i'm never able to
communicate a physical threat to anybody
uh or that i've had bad food um
you know they they played uh i'm
thinking right now in young adult they
there's a scene where you have to listen
to that song yeah and uh and and you
could
was that because did the director know
that you hated that
during that song no jason reitman had no
idea he would surprise me there was a
lot of driving in the film and and he
wanted the character to always to be
listening to music and so he would
always surprise me when we were shooting
he'd be you know
um outside of the car and he would just
feed music into the car for me and he
he was rolling and that he played that
song
and my face he said he said my face
literally looked like they were like
someone farted in the car like it was
like instantly like my nose started like
i was and that's and that's your real
reaction and it's in the movie it's in
the movie and nobody knows but it was
because of that horrible woman
flew all the way to turkey
we actually took i heard about this so
we went and took a still this is the
actual moment where you hear the song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's what i that's the look i gave
her really really you're gonna do this